how much flack have you gotten for this
beyonce bar
ain't nobody say nothing to me
i do like how you preface the bar with
uh if you guys are swingers uh
and in general uh that that
ruby rose replied to your to your uh
to your to be
honest and this with all due respect
that's one of the most beautiful women
in the world
like
i sit in the trap with all the monsters
they say the same thing like all i did
is say what everybody think
that's fair you're the most beautiful
woman in the world like i would drink
your piss like
what the [ __ ] like come on man like what
the [ __ ] beyonce's pissed obviously yeah
right here in my mouth what's that but
i'm just saying like
you got to think i speak for the [ __ ]
that's incarcerated that sit there and
watch these people on tv and everything
this is what everybody's thinking
this is true i mean beyonce is we always
have talks like
that's like that's like say if this was
right here this you know this is my
water bottle this my wife
i feel good knowing that
everybody in the world won't
this what i have what's mine
yeah i'm winning yeah
i'm living y'all dreams every night so
you know
people the other people that took a
disrespect y'all just scared to say but
y'all scared to be
who y'all are i guess
by the way i don't put that much thought
into stuff i just speak from the heart
at what point in time did you realize
in life
that squirt was pissed
it's not
it kind of is i just say that but it's
not it's like it's like a portion of it
is because you're i got a question okay
for you yeah
every woman that you've been intimate
with sexually
were they squirtles
i think every woman is a squirter every
woman is a squirtle but did you make
every
woman that you've been with sexually
squirt every woman that i cared everyone
i cared about yes
because
to make a woman squirt is a art
i agree it's an art
like i i feel like any woman i ever was
with that i cared about pleasing yes
it's a release right so it's an art
if
if i don't make this woman come if i
don't make this woman squirt
i didn't do my job as a professional
dixman
like i didn't get a i didn't get a a on
my dig report your dick report card yeah
yeah so
i want to always you know
this is a brand name
i want to always have a good dick report
you know and i and i mean that with all
due respect
to whoever listening you know what i'm
saying listen buddy we i'm there over
here over here
over here
i look at a woman like art
like
i ain't gonna please my partner my
pleasure activists
i get off on seeing whoever i'm
intimately involved with get off my
partner